l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Madame Catherine procasscia
monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ma question porte sur le la problème de
l'usurpation des plaques
d'immatriculation des
véhicules selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur le phénomè est en
augmentation et il y aurait eu près de
17500 délit ancé en 2012 selon le
ministère soit une hausse assez
affolante de plus de 73 % sur un an
quelle que soit la raison qu'il s'agisse
d'échapper au contrôle automatique des
radars au péag au stationnement payant
ou pire à l'obligation
d'assurance certains se font graver des
plaques avec le numéro d'un autre
automobiliste c'est alors la victime qui
reçoit les amendes se voir retirer les
points sur son permis et euh peut se
retrouver avec des saisies pire pour
elle s'il y a la doublette parfaite
c'est-à-dire si son numéro minéralogique
a été imposé sur une voiture de même
modèle les conséquences financières et
administratives sont alors très lourde
pour la victime elle devra non seulement
prouver sa bonne foi par des témoignages
des attestations de présence mais aussi
attendre qu'on lui rende qu'on lui rende
justice ainsi il a fallu 2 ans de
procédure à un automobiliste du
valdemarne mon département pour faire
classer sans suite 49 procès verbaux
éviter 2000 € d'amende empêcher le
Trésor public de saisir ses compte alors
que l'individu qui avait usurpé sa
plaque d'immatriculation avait été
interpellé loin d'être un cas isolé ce
cas relève du vide juridique des
usurpations d'identité je ne comprends
pas pourquoi alors que l'article R 3178
du code de la route prévoit que tous les
véhicules à moteur doivent être équipés
de plaqu et que l'arrêté du 9 février
2009 précise les caractéristiques et le
mode de pose de ces plaques pourquoi
aucun texte n'encade la fabrication leur
fabrication non seulement l'acheteur
n'est pas obligé de fournir un
certificat d'immatriculation ni même un
titre d'identité mais le distributeur
n'est soumis à aucun contrôle ainsi de
nombreux sites internet et quelques
professionnel ne demande aucun
justificatif quels sont madame la
ministre euh les raisons de cette
absence d'encadrement et de contrôle de
cette source de délinquence routière
parfois même revendiqué sur les forums
Internet
envisagez-vous le gouvernement de faire
évoluer la législation ou de mettre en
place un agrément pour les distributeur
qui serait dès lors obligé de contrôler
certificat l'existence d'un certificat
d'immatriculation et de tenir un régiste
des gravures merci merci mes chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Hélène
conou mé Ministre chargée des Français
de
l'étranger madame la sénatrice
d'ailleurs tout d'abord veuillez excuser
le le ministre manuel Vals pour son
absence que vous interrogez sur le
phénomène d'usurpation des plaques
d'immatriculation alors le cas bien
particulier de l'usurpation du numéro
d'immatriculation pour lequel existe une
procédure spécifique a parfois été
confondu avec les problèmes de
verbalisation indu lié à la vente d'un
véhicule aujourd'hui réglé je souhaite
tout d'abord rappeler que le fait de
mettre en circulation ou de faire
circuler un véhicule portant un numéro
d'immatriculation attribué à un autre
véhicule qui constitue une usurpation
est un délit sévèrement sanctionné
conformément à l'article l317 41 du code
de la route il est passible de 7 ans de
prison et de 30000 € d'amende
indépendamment des poursuites pénales
qui sont menées à l'encontre des
contrevenant une procédure de changement
d'immatriculation existe afin de
répondre à ce type de difficulté
les victimes peuvent ainsi demander en
préfecture à bénéficier d'un nouveau
numéro d'immatriculation sur
présentation du dépô de plainte effectué
auprès des forces de l'ordre un nouveau
numéro est alors délivré sans donner
lieu au paiement de la taxe régionale
les infractions commises avec l'ancien
numéro ne sont plus attribuées aux
personnes dont l'immatriculation a été
usurpé cette procédure protège les
victimes d'usurpation de leur numéro
d'imatri culation de toute verbalisation
indue
elle est d'ailleurs bien utilisée par
nos citoyens comm en témoigne les 1160
opérations de
réimmatriculation suite à usurpation qui
ont été enregistrées en 2012 dans le
système d'immatriculation des véhicules
pour contester les amendes déjà reçues
la victime d'usurpation peut en outre
déposer une requête en exonération
auprès de l'officier du ministère public
compét par lettre recommandée avec
accusé de réception dans un délai de 45
jours en joignant le récipic du dépôt de
plainte aucun paiement de l'amende et
aucune consignation ne sont à faire dans
ce cas une autre mesure protectrice a
été mise en œuvre avec la saisie du
champ marque du véhicule désormais
effectué lors de la constatation des
infractions de stationnement relevé par
procèsverbal électronique cette mesure
permet de détecter une incohérence avec
le champ marque retourné par le système
d'immatriculation des véhicules et
d'éviter l'envoi d'un avis de
contravention au titulairire d'un CC
d'un certificat d'immatriculation d'un
véhicule d'une autre marque dont le
numéro d'immatriculation aurait été
usurpé en ce qui concerne les problèmes
de verbalisation indu suite à la vente
d'un véhicule une difficulté est apparue
en 2011 notre droit considérait que
c'est le titulaire du certificat
d'immatriculation qui était le
responsable du véhicule de ce fait
lorsqu'une infraction était commise par
un nouvel acquéreur avant qu'il n'est
procédé à la réimmatriculation du
véhicule à son nom l'ancien propriétaire
pouvait se retrouver injustement
sanctionné la loi numéro
02011 1862 du 13 décembre 2011 relative
à la répartition des contentieux et à
l'allègement de certaines procédures
juridictionnel publié le 14 décembre
2011 a remédié à ce problème en
modifiant les les articles l1212 et
l1213 du code de la route le vendeur du
véhicule n'est plus destinataire des
contravention survenue postérieurement à
la session du véhicule quand bien même
le nouvel acquéreur n'aurait pas encore
procédé à l'arrêt immatriculation du
véhicule à son nom les mesures ainsi
prives doivent permettre de répondre aux
difficultés causées aux automobilistes
si ce sujet continue à faire l'objet
d'un suivi vigilant il n'apparaît pas
nécessaire aujourd'hui d'un introduire
une réglementation nouvelle concernant
l'activité économique de vendeurs de
plaques d'immatriculation qui aurait
notamment pour effet d'alourdir la
charge des préfectures merci Madame
madame
procassère merci madame la ministre de
cette réponse très complète qui va être
utile aux victimes et effectivement le
fait de pouvoir se faire
rimmatriculer doit être davantage connu
mais j'avais er effectivement le le
ministre de l'Intérieur sur l'absence de
réglementation et je dois dire que là
c'est bien on s'attache à régler les
problèmes des victimes mais on ne
s'attache pas du tout à la fraude et la
fraude en matière c'est que n'importe
qui peut se faire faire une plaque
d'immatriculation n'importe comment euh
je peux vous dire qu'il y a quelques
années j'ai été faire une plaque
d'immatriculation à la date anniversaire
d'un ami pour lui offrir on m'a
absolument rien demandé euh donc euh
c'est ce fait qui pose problème puisque
maintenant les les victimes
seraient mais je doute un peu que le
Trésor Public arrête aussi facilement
euh de continuer à envoyer euh des
rappels euh le temps que la procédure
soit en place puisque les cas que je
vous citais sont quand même des
personnes qui ont eu des difficulté donc
pour les victimes la procédure je note
qu'elle date de 2011 d'ailleurs est un
petit peu plus efficace euh mais
n'empêche que des tas de professions
sont réglementées et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi cette réglementation n'existe
pas vous dites que c'est une tâche de la
c'est un une charge pour la préfecture
mais on peut se faire faire une plaque
d'immatriculation dans n'importe quel
département en plus avec le nouveau
système d'immatriculation c'est encore
plus facile de regarder une voiture de
dire que c'est euh BZ 535
Ed et vous mettez 536 c'est encore plus
facile qu'auparavant de faire
immatriculer et de faire une fausse
plaque d'immatriculation qu'auparavant
euh lorsque c'était par département donc
ce n'est pas une charge pour les
préfectures puisque c'est pas les
préfectures qui peuvent contrôler les
fausses places d'inmatriculation il y a
plus les départements donc euh très bien
pour les victimes on pourra faire
l'information mais je regrette je ne
pense pas que les plaques
d'immatriculation soient vraiment une un
apport important pour les fabricants
puisque la plupart du temps c'est quand
on achète les véhicules donc c'est tous
les revendeurs et les revendeurs de
plaques sans aucun contrôle comme sur
Internet souvent il n'y a aucun contrôle
merci